and the previous episode of Walking Dead
what if my parents come home and I'm not
there I've got my walkie talkie in case
we tried out
I know your bet why did you buy delay
No welcome tart God wherever seniors I
have to find her
Oh God don't let them get to her [ __ ]
Benny
hotels around the corner fine Clementine
and me as soon as he came back whoa oh
oh [ __ ] there is I got a sick joining
room you're not taking her I said no
okay maybe not for climbing she had to
kill a man
maybe it was better if she she's let go
with him oh okay it's okay don't cry
you'll make me cry you look horrible
you should have seen it out let's just
get somewhere safe you don't smell good
yeah be carrying him you couldn't have a
lot of time coming which star okay I'm
sorry Lee I'm sorry okay
it's okay sweetie need to get you
somewhere safe then we have to talk okay
yeah
everything's okay now need to figure out
how to get out of the van as fast as we
can
Hey
you weren't afraid I was you didn't act
like it I know I am now it's okay which
way out through there okay well well
[ __ ] you go through here then well
yes and while I'm older did
hey whatsapp can I have a kiss he's
blind that's the door that's the last of
line hey it didn't bite you yeah oh
that's fine how to get through a bunch
of room to get here so now they realize
that if they get out of Survivor yeah
it's the same in there The Walking Dead
a TV series they try to sneak by zombies
by making themselves like full of their
blood so I guess that's drug Rakhal even
on clammy
that's disgusting hahahahaha which means
you have to do they actually mean is it
okay yeah oh [ __ ]
that's not a bad idea
sure you get you thought you had to grab
but okay I'm hold a whole I'm just doing
it okay so I think anything that's
infected by bite if you get in contact
with the blood somehow it's more or less
should be infected by it in my opinion
so you can't just [ __ ] do that in my
opinion or maybe you should get it in
the eye that should get in the blood
system at least we should technically be
the same way as getting bitten you like
it I should be hot nice nice not would
you like it I would have taken the
sheets from the better over me and maybe
back then before I want to be sure it's
kind of started raining it's kinda
started raining a little I'll try to run
this oh yeah your hat I thought it was
gone I thought you were gone
thank you it's Kelly I am glad that okay
card the gun right next to me walk very
slowly
don't look around and don't panic mm-hmm
I'll keep you safe and what we don't
need the walkie-talkies anymore I guess
I thought whoa
yeah the year the Thunder is gonna rain
it's got a [ __ ] rain oh [ __ ]
that's not good I would be an awesome
zombie this is [ __ ] up man
this is [ __ ] thought and where all the
dead bodies from him coming here
well why are we going exactly what I'm
worried that Lee is gonna turn now and
claim is in danger or something like
that he needs to talk to her know what
is it her pants no it's your mom
it is her mom I remember the photo
hello
for a little girl
we wake up please don't be dead please
no oh he does not look good now Zambelli
I thought you left me oh my parents I
know they didn't get to you right no we
got away Oh cry they did for sure so
there you have to get out of here as
fast as we can
well we can't there's thousands of them
outside I'll protect you no no that's
crazy
I saved you we're safe here I locked us
in get that door open I can't do it
hey don't yell at her it was only a
little open when I found it I closed it
to keep us safe
oh you did a good job honey don't pull
on three one two three
it's not gonna work
Clementine bunny
Oh what happened no no no that's that's
not no no no no yes it is it's gonna be
okay climb a tree you will go to pee
okay we just have to think and work
together okay
he does not look good so good we should
have chopped the arm up but I guess
technically it didn't matter I think
there might be a way out over there
there's zambie and yes a gun though good
sitting there but a chill zombie my
beautiful slow I'll help you alright
hmm I got you you can lean on me
you have to I'm okay I'm okay I thought
I was helping by bringing you in here
don't worry Chloe yeah oh dear daddy
it's awful out there they put two beer
it was hard I don't know how you did it
but you did good okay keep going
we're almost there oh sorry
get up Lee the door is right here
it's over for thee I can't
you have to ma'am icky boo is it for me
here please please try to get up come on
Lee
final effort man I can't you don't have
much time
you gotta do something there's
you're gonna have to make sure I don't
turn you won't know feel I will you know
what you have to do no I can't there's
no way we'll figure it all out
don't worry
just start by getting that door open he
flashed the girl big deal it's just a
glass window wait no that's with your
hand there's a baseball bat under the
couch clip you can use that
use the bat to shut that window so you
can reach in okay watch out for broken
glass afraid of a money you're slow
yes smarted off are they doing taking a
Shea we have some dead clear I know
we'll meet you in there don't worry
doing good that's a Jeremy how again
grab the children easy to reach in to
the lock we got the door straight this
will be easy did he scare the gas
probably to that door and everything you
need
this keys the ground
get him
are you gonna hang cuff him
yeah your friend whoa
that is not again man but the head cuffs
on me attach me to this white matter
what happens
safe I know
just do it make sure you see [ __ ] that
guy just tell him he's him in the gun
G's in the gun just afraid didn't think
it's dangerous faster than he is first
you have to make a run horn aah no aah
grab it watch oh no not lemming I'll
thank God
whoa
this is not good baseball bat that did
not go as expected she's good my garden
good job Clementine come here come here
yeah but you did this smart
what what are we going to do my parents
it's all wearable oh I can't imagine
sleepy no no you please please don't be
one of them please don't become a walker
there's only one thing you can do you
know that I don't know if I can
you have to shoot me honey we know it's
okay it's okay make it first days we met
yeah I do when I went out to rescue that
boy clear met a girl she'd been bitten -
all she wanted was to come back as a
walker we remember how hard it was to do
that well I'm glad I did you don't wanna
see me like one of them okay Lee I could
do it why can't he do it again
I know meeting Krista probably looking
for us right now stay on high ground
don't go too far that you'll find
they'll take good care of you
keep that hair short hey will
I'll cut it myself all right good and
also
what what is it no don't worry all right
me too
you
you
oh okay
it does continue that's what I was kind
of expecting Clementine is walking all
alone she didn't find Ahmed or Krista
she gonna kill herself
I hope she doesn't do it
you can't use shotgun bullets what
you're going to find Osama ding Christa
what's going on there
and she will like stay away from them as
I
what's going on here well I guess
they're hinting us second season pretty
much where we're following Clementine
instead then what the [ __ ]
III don't know what happened that is
just weird for me uh-huh I don't know I
don't I don't even know I I don't I
don't think I'm like sensitive to these
kind of things I guess I usually just
think it's stupid and cheesy but when
you when you go through an adventure
like this it's it's it's hard when you
actually care about the characters and
and not cracking out when things do it
because they do as they do I will I will
I was holding back like it's not like I
was trying to cry on purpose or any [ __ ]
like that it just [ __ ] came let's
just move on and forget this all this
happened all right get um yeah I don't
feel like there's much else needed to be
said just like afraid if you enjoyed the
Skycam right today uh I'll see you next
episode of Iowa
you
you